Rellena los espacios en blanco
para formar
un sistema de ecuaciones lineales
con las variables "x" y "y" con soluciones infinitas.
Y bueno, si vamos a tener
una infinidad de soluciones
esencialmente lo que tenemos que
hacer es hablar de la misma recta.
Deben de ser la misma ecuación
y deben tener la misma construcción.
Así que por ejemplo si aquí partimos con
ésta que es "-5x" más "7y" igual a 1
y si nosotros queremos verla graficada,
¿cómo se vería?
Bueno, pues déjame dibujar aquí,
un par de ejes,
voy a decir que éste es mi eje de las "y"
y por acá tengo a mi eje de las "x",
ok, vamos a poner que
este es mi eje "y",
ok este es mi eje "x" y si yo quisiera graficar
esta función que tengo aquí , bueno,
¿qué te parece si a ésta la pasamos a su forma
pendiente ordenada al origen?
Y para eso voy a despejar a "y".
Me va a quedar,
7 veces "y" es lo mismo que,
éste va a pasar para acá,
del otro lado con signo positivo,
estoy sumando "5x" de ambos lados,
entonces me quedaría "5x" más 1, ok.
Ahora nos falta quitar este 7 y para quitar
este 7 voy a dividir todo, todo, entre 7
y por lo tanto me va a quedar que "y" es lo
mismo que 5 entre 7 por "x",
estoy dividiendo todo entre 7
más 1 entre 7, de lujo.
Y si te das cuenta,
aquí tenemos una recta
que corta al eje de las "y" en el valor de 1/7,
estamos más o menos por aquí,
ok, éste es mi valor de 1/7
y después tenemos una pendiente positiva de 5/7,
por lo tanto, la función se vería más o menos así,
esta ecuación lineal se va a ver de este estilo.
Ahora, si nosotros lo que queremos es tener
una infinidad de soluciones,
lo que voy a buscar es que tengamos
exactamente la misma recta,
es decir, que mi otra recta sea
exactamente ella misma para que
así cada uno de los puntos
sea una solución de este sistema,
es decir, estamos superponiendo a cada "x" y "y",
que satisfaga la primera ecuación.
Y bueno, la forma más fácil de llegar a
esta solución es trabajando
esta ecuación que tengo aquí y
manipulándola de manera algebraica,
de tal manera que lleguemos a una ecuación que sea
y que represente la misma ecuación de aquí arriba.
Y bueno, para hacer esto, aquí tenemos una
clave, aquí en un inicio tenemos un 1
y este 1 va a pasar a convertirse en 3 y de aquí,
de 1 a 3, lo que estoy haciendo es multiplicar por 3
y si estoy multiplicando por 3
y quiero que esta ecuación se mantenga,
entonces todo lo tengo que multiplicar por 3,
esta parte habrá que multiplicarla por 3
y esta otra parte también
habrá que multiplicarla por 3,
de tal manera que voy a multiplicar
por 3 toda esta igualdad
y entonces esta igualdad se va a mantener
y si multiplico por 3 me va a quedar,
3 por -5 lo cual es -15, ok,
"-15x", 3 por 7 es 21 más "21y"
esto es igual a 1 por 3, lo cual es 3.
Y ok, aquí ya tengo representada
a la misma ecuación
porque estoy multiplicando todo
por una misma constante,
lo cual me representan dos rectas
exactamente iguales
y eso quiere decir que tenemos un
sistema de ecuaciones con soluciones infinitas.
Y de lujo, es justo lo que quería.
Ahora vamos a hacer otro...
otro problema
y para eso voy a quitar este problema de aquí
y vamos a traer el siguiente problema...
éste de aquí...
éste es mi otro problema y dice,
¿cuál de las siguientes opciones de "c"...
aquí está "c"...
resultará en un sistema de
ecuaciones lineales sin soluciones?
Y tengo dos ecuaciones.
"5x" menos "2y" igual a 6,
"10x" menos "4y" igual a "c".
Y vamos a marcarlo,
justo aquí tenemos a "c".
Y bueno,
si queremos no tener soluciones,
esencialmente tendríamos que tener la misma
combinación de "x" y de "y"
pero igualadas a dos
números distintos o bueno,
tal vez otra forma de pensarlo
es decir que si graficamos,
estas dos ecuaciones,
entonces tenemos dos rectas
con la misma pendiente
pero que intersectan al eje "y"
en valores distintos.
Ahora, ¿qué te parece
si lo pensamos  de la primera forma?
Si lo queremos ver de la primera forma,
entonces vamos a buscar que ésta,
esta ecuación de abajo
tenga la misma construcción en "x" y "y"
se vea igual que esta ecuación de arriba,
solamente que vamos a hacer
que la parte izquierda sea distinta.
Entonces voy a manipular esto
de una manera algebraica
para que la parte izquierda se vea exactamente igual que la parte izquierda de esta ecuación de arriba,
mientras que la parte derecha
lo que vamos a hacer es justo restringir a "c".
Y bueno, para esto date cuenta que estamos muy,
pero muy cerca,
entonces lo que voy a hacer es dividir todo entre 2,
voy a dividir esta ecuación entre 2,
voy a dividir todo entre 2,
para que así podamos obtener
la misma construcción en "x" y en "y"
y si te das cuenta,
vamos a llegar a lo siguiente.
Vamos a llegar...
y déjame ponerlo con este color...
a "5x"... a "5x" menos 4 entre 2 es 2,
2 veces "y", esto es igual a "c" entre 2... a "c" entre 2.
Y ahora, quiero que te des cuenta,
que en este momento ya tenemos la misma
parte izquierda de las dos ecuaciones,
es decir, la misma construcción para "x" y para "y", "5x" menos "2y" y ahora lo que queremos es que 6,
que esta parte de aquí sea distinta a esta parte de aquí, porque si fueran iguales,
regresaríamos al caso anterior,
regresaríamos a tener la misma recta...
y es más, déjame apuntarlo...
si "c" entre 2 fuera exactamente igual a 6,
entonces tenemos la misma recta...
tenemos la misma recta que es el caso anterior...
y bueno, podemos decir que tenemos la misma recta, entonces tenemos la misma ecuación...
ecuación...y entonces podemos decir que tenemos
las mismas restricciones...
restricciones... ok...
Ahora, recuerda qué pasó en el caso anterior.
En el caso anterior
teníamos la misma recta y entonces
teníamos una infinidad de soluciones,
en este caso tendríamos infinidad de soluciones...
soluciones...ok...
Pero lo que queremos es
no tener una infinidad de soluciones,
sino tener un sistema sin soluciones.
Y bueno, para eso vamos a pensar
qué es lo que tenemos si "c" entre 2 es distinto de 6...
si "c" entre 2, esto es distinto de 6...
si "c" entre 2 es distinto de 6,
entonces no va a haber ninguna "x" y "y"
que pongamos aquí que cumpla ambas ecuaciones.
Fíjate bien, si encontramos una "x"
y una "y" que satisfaga la primera ecuación
entonces "5x" menos "2y" sería igual a 6
y si lo ponemos aquí, esto nos daría 6,
pero esto es algo distinto de 6,
por lo tanto no cumple la otra ecuación.
Y en este caso nos estamos encontrando un
sistema de ecuaciones que no tienen solución...
no tienen...
no tiene solución...
solución...
Ok, otra forma de verlo,
sería multiplicar todo por 2,
"c" sea distinto de 6 por 2 = 12,
esto es un sistema que no tiene...
tiene solución...
solución... solución...
Y bueno, es que si "c" fuera 12,
entonces 12 entre 2 sería 6 y llegamos a este caso,
por lo tanto ya podríamos poner que la respuesta
es cualquier número excepto el 12...
cualquier número excepto el 12
es nuestra solución.
Y bueno, también hay otra forma de verlo,
también podemos pensar que cada una de estas
dos ecuaciones representa una recta
y por lo tanto para no tener soluciones,
lo que vamos a querer es que sean rectas paralelas,
es decir, que tengamos la misma pendiente,
pero que tengamos distinta intersección con el eje "y".
Y bueno, para eso
¿qué te parece si trabajamos las dos ecuaciones y las ponemos en la forma pendiente-ordenada al origen?
Así que déjame empezar con la primera.
Ésta de aquí se va a ver así.
Si yo despejo a "y" voy a obtener que -2 veces "y"
es lo mismo que 6 menos "5x", ok,
lo único que estoy haciendo es restando "5x" de ambos
lados y ahora si divido todo entre -2,
voy a obtener que "y" es igual,
primero me voy a tomar a éste
y me va a quedar menos entre menos más 5/2,
5/2 de "x" y después 6 entre -2,
lo cual es -3, ok, de lujo.
Ahora, esta ecuación es la forma pendiente-ordenada
al origen, de ésta de aquí.
Si nosotros nos fijamos en la otra,
si nos fijamos en ésta
y la ponemos también en la forma
pendiente-ordenada al origen,
¿qué voy a obtener?
Que "-2y" es igual a "5x" negativo,
porque éste pasa con signo contrario
y a esto le voy a sumar, "c" entre 2, ok,
y ahora si divido todo, todo entre -2,
voy a obtener que "y" es igual a
menos entre menos me da más,
5/2 de "x", "5/2x" más...
aquí me quedaría todo dividido entre -2 y por lo tanto,
éste va a ser menos "c" entre 2 entre 2,
me va a quedar "c" entre 4.
Y si te das cuenta,
estas dos rectas tienen la misma pendiente,
tienen una pendiente de 5/2
y yo lo que voy a buscar es que no sean la misma recta,
es decir que sean paralelas.
Y para eso lo que voy a buscar
es que esta parte sean distintas.
Y ahora fíjate bien,
si tuviéramos una "c" igual a 12,
entonces me quedaría 2 entre 4,
lo cual es 3 y aquí la intersección sería la misma,
-3 y -3, por lo tanto hablaríamos de la misma recta,
pero como queremos rectas paralelas,
entonces lo que vamos a buscar
es que "c" sea distinto de 12.
Entonces lo que vamos a pedir,
es que "c" sea cualquier número excepto el 12
y entonces vamos a encontrar
2 rectas paralelas.